Russia enemies see them driven before
you hear a lamentation of the women okay
next one on the list is Conan the
Barbarian 1982 the original I first saw
this in the theater actually in
California in 1982 I don't think I saw
this in the theater I think I saw it I
probably saw it on HBO or some [ __ ] when
I was growing up I saw it in the theater
and I loved it and it wasn't rated R
movie and I wasn't able to see it really
have too young to see it
no one snuck you in I stuck myself in it
now the British audience how to get rid
of this [ __ ] cuz I know the British you
know they're they're very worried about
what what the ratings are you know
little kids can't see anything it's all
blah blah blah okay what we used to do
is we find out when the r-rated movie
was gonna start and we actually say well
what starts right before that well if it
was PG and get a ticket for that PG
movie and go in there and see it and
wait 10 15 minutes for the r-rated movie
to start walk out of the theater and
just jump into the yeah into the r-rated
theater there weren't rushers yeah I
don't think there's Esther's today they
only come in after the only care about
how old you are how old you are when you
buy the ticket yeah and what to end the
ticket that you buy once you get into
the theater you can go into any movie
you have to think that most of the
people that work in movie theaters are
teenagers or are making like minimum
wage they give two [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
was just just to look good on paper it
didn't actually make a difference let's
talk about Conan I saw Conan and 82 in
California on the big screen and it was
fantastic and then they would play it
forever
like on HBO remember it was always on it
was always on how I liked it but it
didn't have that same impact because it
just doesn't look as cool cathode ray
tube television really look good in
normal HD but I got the blu-ray now it
looks fantastic it really takes you back
to the original what it was like to see
it you know on a big screen is it
slightly different cut it's got a
different ending yeah that was something
I was kind of
interested to see it's not like a very
long thing but it's like a scene that
was put at the end that they actually
took out of the theatrical release yeah
put it back in and it makes a big
difference
mythically yeah that's that's why I'm
like I wondered why that well I don't
wonder why I know the why they probably
took it out but then taking that out
made like kind of a big impact on the
story like it kind of changed the whole
thrust or the theme of the story I
thought yeah well what they did was this
is John Milius who's the director of
this he was like a real hero worshiper
he wanted to go into the military but he
couldn't get in because he had asthma
and he liked military stuff and warrior
type culture his last or one of the last
films before this one it bombed so badly
the one he was working on that he
threatened to send himself to the French
Foreign Legion but they put him on Conan
and while the whole time that he
directed Conan he wore a French for
French foreign Legionnaires beret Conan
then really meets the high it's just an
action flick they're just like a sword
and sandals kind of epic yeah it's
really the best one of them all there's
really only well there's really only one
cone a movie and it's this one you don't
want to see Conan the Destroyer yes
reboot you don't wanna see crawl the
Conqueror you don't want to see any
other crap there's only one good movie
one good barbarian warrior movie and
that's Conan the Barbarian this one from
1982 and it has a lot of subtext going
back to like the the great German
philosopher is like Friedrich Nietzsche
and Arthur scope and Hauer and a lot of
you know they were bringing Eastern
philosophy to the west back in the 1800s
you know and this movie goes right along
with that you know I mean the Bushido
code all that stuff's hidden in there
but the movie seems very simple on the
surface but there's a there's quite a
complicated kind of deep subtext and
there's really a lot of stuff going on
in this movie which I didn't really
realize cuz I wasn't a huge action movie
fan I wasn't like a huge sword and
sandals kind of fan and I didn't really
I don't even think I read any of the
Robert E Howard books I might have read
one or two when I was a kid but you know
it wasn't really a genre that made much
an impact so I saw it back in the 80s
but then when I saw it just recently I
was like man there's a lot of like stuff
going on there's a lot of like symbolism
and there's a lot of like callbacks to
like different mythical heroes and stuff
like that and not all of it I mean
because the story wasn't taken like
exactly from the Robert E Howard no it
was made up of the best stuff yeah oh
yeah they picked and chose like you know
and they took stuff from other mythic
figures and stuff and kind of folded it
all into one tale now the original
script I don't know if it was the
original script but one of the first
shooting scripts was written by Oliver
Stone right yeah he was working on it no
his could have intended quite crazy yeah
we heard it was super batshit yes hyena
headed men and women I mean they almost
made the movie post-apocalyptic - almost
- almost about me yeah after apocalypse
but actually I think when John Milius
took over as director and stuff like
that I think he ended up using most of
Oliver Stone's scripts like for the
first half of the first half but then
the second one he just rewrote all of it
I like this movie so much that this they
should have showed this to us like two
weeks into basic training for army
infantry soldier values to it the
meaning of the movie is actually veiled
in this thing that they have that they
called the riddle of Steel and what the
riddle of Steel was about is that
originally there was this was gonna be
three movies so what do they call it
trill ejq trilogy first one was gonna be
about steel second one which is which is
like the strength of a man I guess you
could say strength and then how to use
that strength was gonna be in the second
one and the third one was gonna be the
consequences now they're thinking about
making a third cone a movie with honest
words never yeah King Conan which may
actually get back to the original idea
and it may be they just pretend that the
second one didn't exist what I'd like to
do what are the consequences of being a
badass warrior in your old age yeah part
of the consequences would be like you
know how do you remain relevant in old
age right now as
or that kind of stuff but we'll see if
they actually make it it's been in
development hell I see it sounds like a
good idea might be this movie is
partially narrated by one of Conan's
friends that he meets later there's a
sorcerer played by a guy named Mack oh
and you just know it has a sorcerer
that's the only that's the name of that
character with a crazy back yeah you
know it's got a real famous monologue in
the beginning you know these all the
days of hard you know adventure and all
that originally it was going to be
narrated by Conan himself and I saw one
of the prototypes of Conan doing his
narration and it was gonna start off
with Conan as an old man saying my
vision is going bad I can barely see but
sit down with me and I'll [ __ ] I'll
teach you how I got here in the times of
high adventure and one all this means
you know I think it would have been cool
and yeah in the commentary you know you
have Milius in the car and the
commentary of my blu-ray you have Millis
and Arnold Schwarzenegger making
comments and they were always think of a
man we should recut this do it the right
way you know and it's because the
studio's didn't trust Arnold
Schwarzenegger this is his first movie
and they didn't think the audience could
understand him yeah and although he only
has like six lines in the whole movie
what do you expect Conan to sound like
right yeah yeah these are the days of
high adventure dude you know you know
like city buddy from California cone ass
should sound like some kind of a
foreigner well yeah because he's he's
supposed to sound like exotic like it's
from thousands and thousands and years
ago you don't really know exactly where
he's from
yeah they don't really specify I liked
it in the very beginning you see Conan
is a little kid and his dad is teaching
him about steel in the riddle of steel
and basically what he says is he says
that God created steel and they fought
each other over it some of them were
thrown into the earth and after the
battle Steel was just forgotten out on
the battlefield and human men picked it
up
yeah but it's a metaphor though they're
not talking about the steel that swords
are made out of they're talking about
the steel that men and heroes are made
out of so basically it's about okay
here's going to put you take steel you
heat it you Forge it and you quench it
over and over again and it becomes steel
that a good way to put it yeah okay
could this also be a prometheus metaphor
like the gods
Prometheus giving fire to humans yeah
taking fire from the gods that give us a
human's I guess that's a similar kind of
concept now in the story you find out
that after he hears this from his dad
the village gets attacked by enemy
barbarians
yeah and the main leader of the attack
is James Earl Jones okay he's this guy
named thulsa doom now James James Earl
Jones is an Army Ranger he's an ex-army
Ranger snake eater yeah that's what they
that's what they did in the Rangers back
in the day they had and James Earl Jones
tells this story about when he was in
the Army Ranger if you know in the in
the post material yeah that when he was
in the Army Rangers they gave him all a
snake that they had to take care of and
they to sleep with that was their buddy
and at the end of Ranger school they had
to cut his head off and cook and eat it
[Music]
dosa doom comes and attacks the the
village and a bunch of symbolic stuff
happens he steals Conan's father's sword
which is this beautiful sword that they
were showing him Forge it in the very
beginning he takes the sword he leaves
Conan's dad to the dogs remember that
yeah right and then they turn on Conan's
mom and you could see it also dooms
lieutenants they're looking at this
beautiful woman you know they're like
wow isn't she beautiful you know maybe
we can you know use her or take her with
us
Knapp Tulsa to him he just looks at that
beautiful sword and uses that beautiful
sword to cut that woman's head off yep
let's do a friend of babyco dad right
the also doom was he was above all that
you know he was only out there trying to
find the riddle of steel he was into
steel which they get into that later
thence Conan is sold off into slavery as
a young kid and they put him on
something called the wheel of pain and
to name the chapter of that part of the
movie on my blu-ray the wheel of pain
which is a direct reference to the wheel
of suffering and the wheel of sufferance
talked about in Buddhism and has also
talked about of the scope at our and
Friedrich Nietzsche talks about it the
wheel of suffering is about desire in
life we desire things and then these
things kind of disappoint us or they
satiate us we forget about them and then
replaced by something else that we
desire so it's this constant desire and
disappointment desire and disappointment
over and over again it's called the
wheel of suffering and the only way to
get out of that wheel of suffering is to
stop desiring those things yet to become
above it so that's what the wheel of
pain was about aspect of it they're
showing Conan the wheel of pain was like
being grinder grinding wheat Yankee they
were making flour all right now chained
all the kids to it and had to push the
spokes on this big old wheel they just
round and round and round around for
years yeah it was also that was also a
very elegant solution to like showing
conan growing up because it's just over
years and years and he got older and
older he's like pushing the [ __ ] yeah
there's fewer and fewer kids as they're
falling out yeah through weakness and
their weakness is making him stronger
just like in life about natural
selection you know now there's nothing
about in Eastern philosophies and also
in scope and Howard and future Friedrich
Nietzsche they talked about that
existence itself is wrong from a moral
standpoint and this is because
everything imposes on something else
you know wolves eat rabbits and rabbits
eat grass and grass competes with other
grass for sunlight and nourishment even
inanimate objects [ __ ] each other over
but occupying space that another object
could occupy [ __ ] right and the whole
essence of what the will is some some
people call it the force or maybe the
dark side of the force depends on how
you want interpreted the will is about
growth and you grow by in a way taking
taking the food and the nourishment or
taking things from other competitors and
sometimes it's given to you also that
maybe will
leave a link to a little video really
good video about the will to power
that's what it's talking about on the
the wheel of pain so Conan's getting
stronger
his competitions dying off and as they
die he gets stronger in the end he's the
last one they take him and sell him into
slavery to another guy who's a pet
fighter he's basically turned him into a
gladiator and this guy's got he's got
red hair and everything he takes it he
throws him in a pit doesn't tell him
anything he just has to fight this guy
with these sharpened teeth as Conan is
in there fighting he wins his first
battle his second battle in many many
battles and he realizes that through the
narration they tell you that life and
death are about the same thing so he
starts to become kind of above it all
indifferent and what they're referring
to is is that in a lot of these warrior
philosophies especially like in the
eastern ones with like judo and things
like that and some of the Makaveli and
type thinking is that a man becomes a
true warrior when he can give his own
life or take the life of another with
equal indifference
that's the hardcore [ __ ] and it's just
indifference what they're talking about
it's like a a kamikaze mentality this
has talked about you know Friedrich
Nietzsche an arthroscope a tower so they
point out that that's what Conan learned
in the pit but with the reaction of the
crowd the people were cheering and
betting on him he also got a sense of
self esteem through it he realized that
in the wheel of suffering or in life in
the struggle for survival
that he mattered that you have a say in
this you're not just being thrown
through it you know you don't matter you
know I mean it's you do matter
yeah that's what he finds it's what he
finds out with the will - yeah like he
iced out he realized that he had some
measure of control control he wasn't
just pushed around by things that you
can kind of control Herman you take
certain aspects of nature now he got so
good at this his slave master really
started living through him vicariously
his slave master was was reaping all
these material rewards and getting rich
off of Conan but he was not getting the
spirit
to richness that Conan got they sending
to the east he studied under the great
weapons masters they gave art and
philosophy to him in other words you
know they gave him education they even
bred him off with the most beautiful
women of the area but the slave master
himself he wasn't getting all these
warrior virtues himself because he
wasn't in the wheel and there's a scene
where his master just let him go
basically out of out of respect it yeah
in a way he let him go and you can see
that he was crying and Conan did really
didn't want to go he wanted to stay they
kicked him out with nothing and he
kicked him out into the world Conan
didn't know freedom or the world and
what was the world filled with they
originally show you
wool from wolves cuz the first thing
that happens to him when he gets free
gets chased by yeah he doesn't have a
way to make a living he doesn't have a
home nothing he runs up on a big pile of
rocks and falls in through a hole in the
ground and goes down into a subterranean
tomb now this leads back to crawl Conan
believed in the gut and a God that lived
in the earth named crawl but the
director said that tomb that he falls
into is actually the tomb of an
eight-foot-tall
Atlantean general and his harem that was
buried in their life like that magicians
use I do yeah the Chinese used to do it
too yes so Cody and seize this skeleton
huge skeleton in armor sitting on a
throne with this rested old sword next
to him and all these women chained up in
the walls you know they're all dead have
been dead for I guess a thousand years
and he thinks it's crawl and he sees
underneath his hand as a sword and conan
goes to take the sword he takes it away
and clears it off and it's just this
beautiful Atlantean sword that he thinks
his God gave him and while he wasn't
looking it looked like the skeleton
moved and fell and just collapsed and
fell to the ground and Conan you know
wasn't you could tell he wasn't really
sure did it move or did he move it what
the symbolism was is that you had this
great Atlantean general that had
like passed the torch along to his
successor in other words he was kind of
like a benefactor a spiritual benefactor
yeah Coenen he even waiting in the
bowels of the earth for the right person
for the right warrior that comes he
passes the torch along to Conan Conan
submerges out of the ground those wolves
are still there he's got the sword in
his hand and the next scene you see that
Conan is wearing those those wolves and
also it's significant that the first
what are the first things he does with
the sword is to cut the chains off of
himself
that's right cuts a change so it's kind
of symbolic the kind of symbolic of that
Conan inherits a means to make a living
yeah from a successor other than his
father in fact there's a long theme of
having multiple fathers yeah he had his
biological father who taught him the
riddle of steel he had a slave master
father who gave him all of his strength
to turn him into steel you know all of
his strength in his education and then
this new father that gave him a
replacement sword you know the one that
his father had lost his ancestral sword
was now replaced with this Atlantean
sword and then he goes off from the
world to make a living and after he
kills the Wolves he runs into this wolf
which yeah that's a pretty good scene
the wolf which tells him where to find
also doom so he could avenge his
family's death I'm not gonna give the
details of that case you haven't seen it
he also meets chained outside the wolf
which is captive who was super tied
sukkot I was kind of like modeled after
Chinggis Khaan and he's a thief in an
archer and an archer he frees him and
they he becomes kind of like Conan's
first friend yeah he doesn't want
anything from him or anything you know
he's just a friend and he does things
for Conan they've got each other's back
they got each other's backs
later on super tie and Conan go into a
town and it's a real famous scene there
they get high on Stiggy and Black Lotus
says it's basically as LSD
[Music]
is just cracking down on a yak that's
another review and they had some young
guys going why the hell he punch that
camel you can't really see it clear yes
yeah I didn't notice it the first time I
think that kind of darkened it so it
didn't get a next race you can roll with
Beast yeah they come around the corner
they see this dude just cracking down on
a yak and they're high and I go to look
at that if you see them and they're
laughing in kona is backing away from it
like god that's nasty he backs into a
camel turns around him knocks a camel a
because he thought that camel will try
to [ __ ] him you can't see it real
clearly in the in the new blu-ray that
was a very brief you looking guys
reviewing it go what healthy punch the
camel well you didn't see the original
theatrical version you know yeah that
goes guys that got [ __ ] this well of
it was a it was a yama from memory
well they meet this chick named valerian
Valeria's a warrior woman and she's like
total equal to conan and what it means
symbolically is they're saying steel is
not something that just men have steel
is so in other words in that warrior
virtue something that women can have too
and she ends up being like a warrior
equal to him but in some ways surpasses
him later on in the story because
through a woman's that they tie and they
show you this to the story you know in a
mythological kind of mythical way to
show you that a woman in many ways has
kind of a superiority over men in terms
of their ability to empathize and
sacrifice and sacrifice and through that
she eventually gains immortality
as a Valkyrie yeah and actually conquers
death and comes back and saves Conan in
a in combat which that's a really good
part of that story now there's something
that Jenny and I have been working on
they all climb up into the tower what a
salsa dance culture and they fight a big
snake which is kind of symbolic of
making a drag of fighting a dragon but a
serpent is also kind of a reference I
think to
sure oh yeah and Asherah and the eye of
the serpent is a reference to a Shura
and I think it has something to do with
female power just like in the Garden of
Eden I kind of see it as almost like a
reverse Garden of Eden reference yeah
you know what I mean what you have in
this situation there is you have one of
thoughts of Doom's lieutenants running
up a big part of the cult and he's the
only guy there and he's got a bunch of
women who are serving him and they're
sacrificing themselves to this giant
snake in the center of the snakes lair
that they have down there is this thing
called the eye of the serpent and it's a
big Ruby about the size of a fist yeah
now this is some kind of a holy relic or
something symbolic in the story because
at certain times that they show it
certain points you'll see a red glean
that they've added like its Sparkle and
Conan steals that eye of the serpent
later on he gives it to valaria valaria
wears it and it shines at a certain part
right before she kills two enemies this
is later on in the movie and then later
on it's returned to Conan and at one
point thoughts of doom asks Conan where
it is and what he has done with it and
he goes Luxor says you gave it to some
girl
it's almost as it was something that
belongs to women but also doom had taken
from women yeah and Conan returned it
back to women for at least for a while
and then he ends up getting it after
valaria dies do you do you really
understand do you think that there was a
whole pagan female power type of thing
going on too along with the multiple
fathers idea because I was like not only
is there the kind of Garden of Eden
metaphor of like the you know the
serpent and the maybe the ruby
representing like the apple or the the
fruit of the tree of knowledge or
whatever but like I said it's almost
like a reversal because in the Garden of
Eden story you've got in trouble but I
think I think that it kind of represents
like you said like a female power female
yeah knowledge that fell Sadu and the
male portion of the equation hath stolen
his stolen they were denying it from
women
because check this out I find it very
significant that in the beginning when
coin is still a kid and the kid who
plays Conan as a kid looks just like
[ __ ] Neve Campbell from screams
that's her name right it freaks me out
that was like that's a boy but it looks
just like that girl when she was older
weird
so I find it significant that when
thulsa doom rates the village he's
content to let Conan's dad just get
eaten by dogs yeah like yeah whatever
[ __ ] that guy
but Cody ants mom who was standing there
trying to protect the cake she stands in
front of him and she like holds out his
sword tooth also doom like she's gonna
kill him even though there's [ __ ]
hundreds of Ben and he looks at her for
a long time almost like he's hypnotizing
her and then he cuts her head off so I
think he's symbolically taking away her
power taking away female power because
he spent a long time looking at her and
mesmero like he was trying yeah like I
said he didn't just like knock him over
or let the dogs hit him like he's admit
the men Milius said that he was
hypnotizing her but he was above sexual
attraction to women in that way yeah and
that he would at that time was pitying
her for being weak and was taking steel
over it yeah I guess but in some ways
his may have been the perspective that
thulsa
had in some ways though I think that
kind of just feeds into what I'm saying
because the fact that he used the sword
to cut off her head and he's saying oh
well I don't need to rape her I don't
need to do you know what I mean but in
some ways because he used the sword as
almost like a dick metaphor yeah to take
her power away so he almost like
metaphorically raped her rewrite
something yeah there was there's a bunch
of metaphors and yeah yeah and a lot of
symbolism going on like I said the
reason a lot of sword & Sworcery tiger
movies I knew that there was something
up with this eye of the serpent it's not
just a MacGuffin
and I think you're pretty much right
that it's some kind of an Eden reference
it's a it's it's a female symbol some
sort yeah if any if any audience member
really knows any more about her
they understand a little bit better you
can leave it leave it in the comments
section now you find out that eventually
Conan gets captured by Tulsa do thoughts
the DIMM says you know I'm here because
you killed my whole family my mother my
father my tribe and then salsa goes yeah
that was back when I was interested in
Steele and Conan goes oh yeah the riddle
of Steel he goes oh yeah
you know what that is don't you boy he
goes well now that you're here I'll I'll
tell you I'll tell you the meaning of
the riddle of Steel's the least I could
do he says steel isn't strong this flesh
is stronger there's a really cool scene
and what this did what this did for me
is that it makes a connection between
warriors and sorcerers that eventually a
warrior can get so can achieve a certain
amount of enlightenment and when he does
he can transform into a sorcerer and
what I mean by that is is that a warrior
solves problems with his hands a
sorcerer solves problems with his words
and that's kind of what you see going on
you see that Tulsa Doom is kind of like
a Jim Jones cult leader and he's
brainwashed people with a bunch of false
ideas to give up their own natural
preservation to give up their instincts
for natural preservation they're willing
to kill themselves for thulsa doom you
say that killing somebody with a sword
you're killing a person with ideas
killing a person with your words they
serve it in that it's more that it's
more powerful that's not using you know
brute force I also wanted to say there
was actually a really nice parallel
there that I only just thought of where
as celsa Doom was getting everyone to
sacrifice themselves just for him and
for a pointless reason it's significant
that valaria sacrifices herself
willingly willingly because of her love
for a lot right now it's also doom even
though he's a cult leader he's not a
charlatan Millia says that he's the last
survivor of Atlantis of an Atlantean
race of people that they were black
skinned with blue eyes and straight hair
and that they could live for thousands
of years so and you you
seen one seen that though Sidhu can
transform himself into a giant servant
so he is a real wizard he is a real
sorcerer he does have the power so he's
not a fake and what he seems to be doing
you find out later on that the cult has
a secret you take people and you take
away their ability to think for
themselves by giving them kind of like a
pseudo religion that makes them not
focus on their own will but only on the
will of thulsa do in other words they'll
sacrifice themselves and you take this
these people and eventually you kill
them and you use their bodies as food to
feed the other members of the cult so
you come in they fill your head full of
a bunch of you know [ __ ] that they
show like guys balancing rocks on their
heads and trying to search for emptiness
and seeing eternity in water and all
this kind of new-agey [ __ ]
and you take them into the temple and
you have like a big orgy and you give
them drugs and then you get them to
sacrifice themselves and you feed them
to the new incoming uh do you want to be
on the show to you I believe that in
Solaris in the normal cycle of life you
know you have your own desires and your
honor basically you know like I said
like I'm we love pain we have desires
they're fulfilled and then a little bit
of disappointment and a new desire but
what salsa was doing was taking that
same concept and accelerating it into a
shorter period of time yeah I mean yeah
get them high haven't show them a good
time they were calling a paradise
remember yeah and they by the way yeah
you get him to kill themselves and then
you turn them into food for the next
batch yeah getting them to move away
from normal life which that's a pretty
cool idea yeah all right that was his
version of sorcery so you just set up a
death machine like a cult death machine
where people come in take drugs have
orgies eat the bodies of the of the
followers that were
you know came before you and then you
kill yourself yeah weird but and then
you got those back there gaining power
from it somehow maybe he was like eating
their essences or something weren't they
they were throwing themselves into the
giant snake pit right well no other
things yeah but maybe because that was
his snake maybe when it ate the people
that threw themselves in there maybe
that was somehow like transferring like
their essence I'm transferring to NASA
member it wasn't that old Lux or Rex or
whatever his name was raised it okay it
wasn't that old it was just he just fed
off death now originally the ending was
chopped up a lot for the American
audience they simplified it clan
basically just shows up and kills Tulsa
dude there's really not a lot of drama
to it so the interesting thing and we
were gonna talk about this about the end
scene that was cut out now in the
original theatrical cut of the film if I
remember correctly and this is what I
saw on cable - I think Roy it pretty
much ended right when Conan got to the
temple or whatever and killed thulsa
doom this is after a salsa doom tried to
I don't know if he's trying to talk him
out of it but he was saying stuff like
well I'm your father
pretty much it's like you wouldn't be
what you are if it wasn't for me which
is kind of true because I mean Kona's
whole life has kind of the whole thrust
of his life has been toward getting
revenge on this dude right right now
here's one of the things that you know
we failed to mention before the whole
reason one of the side reasons are they
one of the additional reasons that Conan
wants to get it Tulsa dooms a thulsa
doom has possession of a king's daughter
a princess yeah and he's he and his
party have been hired to Rex rescue yes
they came gave him a bunch of joy she
going way into this cult she doesn't
want to go anywhere they capture her
Tulsa doom basically almost kills her
but yeah it's just like oh yeah yes so
she kind of turns on Tulsa do as you
would in the original ending that was
cut out of the American theater three at
Racal release this girl helps Conan get
back into the temple and kill thulsa
doom
right and you they actually show this in
the original version and that's what's
on the blu-ray and there's a bunch of
symbolism that go on in that scene after
Dulce is killed and the main thing was
is that you see is that you see that
Conan had an opportunity to become the
new cult leader right the king's
daughter was getting ready to basically
worship Him as a god yeah I mean after
he killed those two doom he's walking
down the stairs of the temple and all of
the followers are like throwing their
candles down I got [ __ ] this [ __ ] we
gotta do some other [ __ ] Network but so
they're leaving and he's walking down
the steps and the king's daughter i
camera what her name was and i forgot i
did too she's not doing it very much and
um the king's daughter is like walking
right behind him and she runs out in
front of him and boughs down in front of
him as though he is her leader but he
rejects them and he just walks around
there and then she gets up like wow yeah
then he makes her get it where he tells
her to get up or emotions for her to get
up and then it doesn't he like hold his
hand out so yeah and they need together
as equals yeah as if to say you're my
equal I am NOT you're wrong the way I'm
not like felt Sidhu the way I interpret
it after he thought killed Tulsa Doom he
thought about it for a long time there's
a whole scene him yeah or he might have
been thinking about what salsa Doom said
to him about how well now I've killed
him but what do I do now because that
was like my whole mission I believe that
I believed that he was considering
taking over but he actually could've
been yet he and it gets back to the how
Warriors can evolve into sorcerers yeah
and he rejected magic he said no I'm
gonna do it with my hands yeah basically
I wanna be a warrior and you know
there's in the original Conan stories
there's always this thing between
warriors and sorcerers yeah I mean Conan
does not like sorcery is this the same
analogy as a soldier and an intellectual
it's the same analogy yes as no I'm
gonna be a soldier or soldier and
scholar
even though Conan was it as educated he
was educated it's just that he did not
want to seek power through words and
mind control
that's the waves yeah because I think
the whole thing about the wizardry and
everything
I don't know if they were necessarily
saying it was all bad but the way that
the alsa doom wielded it yeah it was bad
because he was using it for mind-control
he was using it for nefarious another
analogy might be soldier and politician
right yeah yeah yeah we could see it
that way too and actually he is probably
a fella siddhim is probably more like a
political or like world leader like said
microphone I actually do think that
Milius might have based him a little bit
on Jim Jones they are fabulous
no but it should be noted that and this
was actually I learned this on the
Wikipedia page
apparently the character of Conan that's
in the books is kind of different than
the Conan that was in the movie you know
in the movie like I said Arnold
Schwarzenegger doesn't really say hardly
anything he is very very he has very
very few lines so like I said I think
that that analogy really holds up where
he doesn't talk much but falsi doom
talks a lot and you know there's kind of
that dichotomy going on yeah evidently
the two brains versus brawn evidently
the Conan from the book is a lot more
educated speaks a lot more yeah it's
like a tactician the Conan that you're
given in the movie is actually the
creation of cherry-picking from the from
the seat from the books also
cherry-picking from the Marvel comic
series and merely us making his own
mythic tale about Conan that's kind of a
morality tale Plus Swartz [ __ ]
sort of thing I made that role of his
own yeah and I think they kind of threw
in some stuff from Norse mythology's
Greek mythology I mean there was a super
dramatic foster manifest it was there
was like a whole crucifixion yes scene
which actually is one of my favorite
scenes the movie where they hang him on
the tree yes the vulture comes like he's
gonna die and stuff like that and he
just takes this thing he takes the
vulture in like white that's neck inhale
so you want to draw parallels with like
a Christian Jesus crucifixion
I don't think so to me look like
Hercules well and the crucifixion on the
tree thing that's more that's where a
Norse thing I thought it's not on a
cross it's on a tree that's like I said
that's older than Christianity these
playing games yeah so I think
I I read that more as a as a Germanic or
a Norse mythology reference rather than
a Christian mythology but this is an
excellent movie it's a movie that you
want to see on blu-ray if you have a
real big TV good sound system it's
awesome the music's awesome
problem it one of the problems though
with the music on this it's not really a
problem but this is one of the last
movies to be recorded in mono really I
did not know that I didn't really notice
it did you know yeah I gotta tell you
something though the theme the coding
the barbarian theme I get it stuck in my
head it was good
musics fantastic and here's the thing
you know what seen it as a kid i I just
saw it as an action movie yeah but see
it is so many years later you know with
you know the books that I've read in
military service and everything under my
belt now that I'm in my 40s I see it
open up with a Friedrich Nietzsche quote
that which does not kill us makes us
stronger and I didn't remember that see
I don't know if that was in the
theatrical version or the cable version
because I thought it was because whether
it's critics of the day I read the
critic see today is a man that kind of
ruins it but they didn't know what they
were talking about and so it opens up
with the Friedrich Nietzsche quote then
I'm hearing riddles of Steel and I'm
going ah yeah okay so this is gonna be a
morality tale this is about philosophy
and then a barbarian attack with Vlad
nari and music in the back and I'm going
yep freaky freaky eat you keep going out
like you called crustle roughly is just
freaky you got freaky vogner
I got scope and how're you got all these
all that stuff happened and it was like
okay I know where Milius is taking me
once he established that with me I just
started looking for the imagery the
imagery and the morality tales and the
philosophies there and the all the
little icons kept popping out at me I
really did like this for I really did
like this movie a lot better than when I
saw it back it's aged very very well it
really has and like you said it's
because yeah you can just watch it as
like a cool actually you know action
movies sword and sandal kind of flick
but then also there's all this other
symbolic stuff going on it's like its
mythic it is a lot of dumb movies no
it's really not
no I mean you know even though you might
single oh this is just this big beefcake
walking around on a bunch of anything
but no there's tons of [ __ ] it has a
very classic and sophisticated subtext
going on with the imagery like I said
it's great there's there's like Beowulf
[ __ ] in there there's like all kind of
[ __ ] in there it's like you know if you
want to see it you don't have to see it
but it is no they have to see it you
have to tom says you see that [ __ ] on
blu-ray with a really big HD TV and a
really good sound system john r would
love this movies probably are there on
your rangers in there the bad guys an
extra army ranger call you know drug
vader was a ranger did you okay I did
not know I didn't know that yeah he ever
seemed like such a nice man dropping
atomic bombs on Russia in his first
movie dr. Strangelove yeah he was in the
air he was in the view - crew oh he was
navigator I think that's his superious
first memory I think was his a movie I
did you see that movie again I haven't
seen an awesome roller yeah James Earl
Jones man come on a dude is a God he is
he's a badass he's a badass on all
levels basically spiritual level his
spiritual intensity is just second he
steals the show in this movie he really
does he's he's a great villain great
villain in this movie
James roll jumps himself said that
thulsa doom was the prehistoric Darth
Vader it is the same character basic
pretty much retold in a difference it's
the same character I'm your father
yeah he even pulls that in it yeah yeah
he does actually I mean he does I don't
know if he uses those words but you'll
see you'll see and he actually does have
the force and this guy's a thousand
years old at least he can turn into a
snake so he's not he's not a normal
mortal man those and actually I really
liked I mean you know it's the 80s so
they did that affect the way they did
did it in the eighties but actually it
looks super cool like all the all the
things they did where we're actually
really nice we have the models and stuff
that they may have looked like real
snakes yeah all practical effects most
of the scene most of the cities were
actually built there were matte matte
paintings but you can barely tell the
sets are
fantastic yeah members old days when
they actually built sets instead of just
like making amends a stupid big axes and
I have to tell you the two guys that are
like salsa dooms like two henchmen yeah
at the beginning and the scene when they
take off their helmets and stuff I'm
like oh look anvil has arrived final
time it actually made a song about co
man of course they say it is called
sonic steel that you're gonna put that
[ __ ] at the end of this video already
so that's our latest movie review well
we went on a long time about this yeah
well it's kind of I wanted to do
something special with this I hope I
rose to the occasion
I hope my warrior virtues came out well
you know I can feel it
and I can see it mythically what's
happening in the story I have a hard
time communicating some time verbally
yeah that's why that's you I have to
tell you though that your warrior virtue
came out so much that you made the
lights in the room go out that yes while
we were recording all the lights in the
room went up the power didn't go out
burn alive also but the light stopped
okay there's three light bulbs in that
and they all went out at the same time
yeah how did that happen well I remember
you this is haven't many times I've told
you that that's happened throughout my
life you know
he's poltergeist and [ __ ] again just you
know excitement you can do it yeah he's
getting he's dead
you broke my office lights so all three
of them went out yeah that's a nice
Psalm all flashing but everything you
paid much attention to yeah I thought it
was just because it's so much about what
five minutes ago yeah well so we're
sitting in the dark so from the dark
hope you enjoyed this movie
retrospective Franco mm wolf yeah he's
got to replace some lightbulbs in my
office so I can see to work alright see
you guys next time
[Music]
you